una histórica oportunidad de paz en uno
de los conflictos más letales del mundo
este sábado iniciaron las conversaciones
entre el ejecutivo afgano y los
talibanes en presencia del secretario de
estado de eeuu my pompeo
soy consciente y sé que todos ustedes
también lo están que sin duda
encontraremos muchos desafíos durante
las conversaciones en los próximos días
semanas y meses cuando esto pase
recuerde que no solo está actuando por
esta generación de afganos sino también
por las generaciones futuras sus hijos
el objetivo es poner fin a un conflicto
armado que ha dejado más de 100.000
muertos durante la última década pero
que lleva casi 20 años cobrando vidas y
sacrificando la estabilidad de
afganistán el negociador del gobierno
agradeció a las partes por su
disposición a negociar y pidió que se
detengan los combates we see you man y
también si es por tu bien buscamos que
se anuncie un alto el fuego humanitario
el alto el fuego nos permitirá brindar
asistencia humanitaria y de desarrollo a
toda nuestra
en todas las regiones de afganistán
wiggins afganistán por su parte el
negociador del talibán reiteró su
llamado a la creación de un sistema
islámico como punto de partida para las
conversaciones afganas también el
creemos que afganistán sea un país
desarrollado independiente y unido y
debería tener una especie de sistema
islámico
la apertura de los diálogos tuvo lugar
un día después del aniversario número 19
de los ataques contra las torres gemelas
y el pentágono que desencadenaron la
intervención militar estadounidense en
afganistán el gobierno de donald trump
quiere poner fin al conflicto más largo
del país mientras busca la reelección el
próximo 13 de noviembre